my name is Kelly chimeric I'm 25 years
old and I'm a freelance audio engineer
some people just stay in one trade one
part of audio I like to do a little bit
of everything so I work in a studio as a
recording and mixing engineer my work in
live sound as a monitor in front of
house engineer in film I'm a production
sound mixer so my main goal is to get
the dialogue on set then in
post-production that's when we focus on
sound effects creating them taking them
from a library fully recording that
footsteps basically recreating the world
that we already recorded in a studio
setting so we have more control over it
so I went to school for business and I
was a vocal minor I had to take an
elective for my vocal classes and it was
called music technology and it was all
about you know microphones and speakers
and music and I was like what like this
is something I can do I just I don't
know why my whole life in music I had no
idea that audio engineering was a thing
once I took that music technology class
I changed my major to multidisciplinary
Studies which is when three minors make
up your major we don't have a music tech
major program so that's how I kind of
finagled it and then I studied theater
and advertising so the theater side of
things I did theater sound design which
audio engineering and theater is huge so
that's a whole nother avenue that you
can study and then advertising because I
knew I was probably gonna have to be a
freelance person and so I wanted to be
able to market myself I graduated from
West Virginia with my Bachelor of
Science and multidisciplinary studies
three years ago and then I immediately
moved out to Denver I didn't have a job
lined up I knew there were studios in
Denver I contacted a bunch of them and
no one wanted anything to do with me so
for about two years out here for the
first year I did nothing but bartend so
I was a bartender all through college
and I was bartending out here as well
and then I found the master's program
and I was like you know what if no one
wants
hire me right now maybe I need to hone
in some more skills and so I decided to
apply for graduate school you don't need
to go to school but it definitely gives
you a leg up on the competition
depending on their experience obviously
so once I started interning I was
interning at this studio in this past
summer and the way that I got that was
just networking those engineer meetup
groups where I go to every studio I
always talk to the owners we had a meet
up at this studio and I came to it and I
was talking to my boss and he said to
call him and so I called him and I set
up my resume and he hired me as an
intern so I interned here for awhile and
over the summer and then at the end of
the summer he hired me on as a freelance
audio engineer randomly I got a call
from a producer in LA I got a call from
a producer in New York all asking me if
I can do production audio for their gigs
and I was like yeah that's awesome and
I'm wondering how they got my name and I
find out it's just from one connection
where I did a good job and so they give
my name out to people one other way I
guess is that I've been getting jobs as
production houses in Denver don't have
audio people on staff and I noticed that
when I was researching different
production houses on their websites they
didn't have audio people so I just
started sending them emails with my
rates if you ever need an audio person
let me know and I've gotten a couple of
calls from people that way as well so
just being super proactive is and saying
yes to everything is how I've gotten
where I am right now